je pense qu'on est dans un dogmatisme
locale et là c'est très inquiétant
on n'est pas là pour prendre la place de
la police nationale mais on a un devoir
aujourd'hui en tant que maire d'assurer
une tranquillité de sécurité dans sa
ville
[Musique]
où
bon
[Musique]
on est en train de diminuer les
effectifs côté brigade de nuit on est en
train d'enlever on va supprimer les
milliers de canines qui était quand même
une brigade qui accompagnait l'équipe de
nuit qui était un fort soutien à la fois
pour dissuader et aussi pour flairer des
des substances interdites qui permettait
à près de faire intervenir la police
nationale et puis concrètement on va se
retrouver dans une logique d'une police
dite de proximité de médiation et donc
quand ils se font face à une situation
complexe
je ne sais pas comment ça va se passer
[Musique]
l'objectif des pâtes faire un usage des
armes mais c'est de se sentir en
sécurité eux aussi sur le terrain et la
ville de villejuif et une vie
particulière puisque comme vous le savez
il ya eu une succession de faits
marquants les années passées aussi bien
l'acte terroriste dans les châtelains
que de janusz qu'une découverte de
fabrique des usines de fabrication
d'explosifs
donc je pense qu'aujourd'hui une police
municipale peut être bien équipé à la
fois pour bien intervenir sur le terrain
et puis de rassurer tous les citoyens
tout simplement
[Musique]
la plus petite paire gazon ce mercredi
nist il va même à l'encontre de ce que
font à la rigueur c'est homologue
communiste dans d'autres villes le
candidat à la présidence nationale
communiste parle de renforcer les
polices municipales et on est encore
dans un temps une non observation de ce
quart passe aujourd'hui sur le plan
national
[Musique]
d
et
le
[Musique]